effectivement ils sont les grandes
victimes de ce conflit
ces enfants plusieurs centaines ou vous
l'avez entendu parmi les blessés
attendre des soins une association
française de médecins la chaîne de
l'espoir spécialisée dans les secours
d'urgence aux enfants attend depuis cinq
jours à jérusalem
l'autorisation de l'armée israélienne de
se rendre dans la bande de gaza ses
médecins ont confié leur amertume à
régis nismo mais olivier tu y es tu
cela fait maintenant cinq jours qu'ils
attendent dans leur hôtel à jérusalem
cinq longues journées à espérer un
éventuel feu vert des autorités
militaires israéliennes pour se rendre
dans la ville de gaza une attente
insupportable pour six chirurgiens
français venu pour sauver des vies met
en colère parce qu'on sait de l'or on a
des contacts téléphoniques avec le
directeur de l'hôpital d'al shifa qui
nous appellent au secours en disant il
ya des enfants blessés comme ceux d'ing
convenue en a besoin de changer
basculèrent de neurochirurgiens et on
peut pas y arriver sur place à gaza la
situation dans les hôpitaux est
catastrophique
les hôpitaux débordés qui manque de
personnels et de moyens pour faire face
à un afflux permanent de blessés alors
pour tenter de passer coûte que coûte
les chirurgiens de la chaîne de l'espoir
cherche d'autres routes le point de
passage avec la bande de gaza il est
fermé
le crs ou l'hypothétique au convoi c'est
la première fois pour voir effectivement
tel blocage une telle interdiction
de la zone de conflit aux organisations
humanitaires généralement plus ou moins
on peut passer plus ou moins l'axé
l'essai ou à l'évacuation des blessés où
l'accès aux médecins sur place là pour
l'instant tout ça est globalement
bloquer un blocage qui dure malgré la
promesse du premier ministre israélien
ehud olmert d'ouvrir des corridors
humanitaires à gaza
ce soir les chirurgiens français nous
toujours aucune garantie de pouvoir se
rendre sur place et encore moins
d'évacuer les enfants les plus gravement
blessés pour les faire soigner en france